[Music]  welcome  king james  i'm a cartoon i'm shorter than kevin  hart  no  [Music]  the computer dude kidnapped my son  the only way you get in your sun back is  if you and i play a little basketball  you want to play me in basketball  i need to  i'll take it from here sam shoot the  ball  let's try that again shall we we'll get  your son back  i promise what's happening  i look expensive introducing  the goon squad  everything you love well at least we're  good  oh and i almost forgot all of the tunes  will be deleted so  come on guys the toon squad doesn't give  up if we're going out  we're going out looney  [Applause]  well that happened wow  we need a booth a secret weapon come on  man granny's out here having a martini  at halftime  [Music]  bye